we said cheerio to the queen of mean
i honestly feel so sorry for you then we
made
rachel regal i've never been treated
like an actual princess
and had a beautiful bake secret
ingredient to chocolate chip cookies is
chocolate this is you're the bachelor
season 25 episode 5 recap grab your
glasses
it's time for roses and rosie
hi everybody it's me lauren zema
and i'm wearing gold hoops today because
all the women wear gold hoops and we are
moving forward
in togetherness what did you think of
this episode
we finally said goodbye
to our queen of mean queen victoria
i honestly feel so sorry for you and i
have to say
cheers to that goodbye
we also had some fabulous one-on-one
dates we're gonna talk about it all
let's get to it oh everyone so i started
off by writing down
we are 30 seconds in and victoria has
said one mean
thing every 10 seconds we haven't even
started the hazing process
oh there's so many it's just disgusting
disgusting this behavior
is not okay the queen has arrived
[ __ ]
in these five episodes victoria has gone
from fun screen queen
to just plain mean carolina's the
dumbest pro i've ever met
and after last week's episode i honestly
had to
give my brain a break i had to find a
way to calm down
on your mark get baked and the solution
was
a perfect bake do you guys watch the
great british baking show
i love this show i really do i've been
watching it for a while but especially
last week because
i needed the perfect combination of
interest
and escapism of oh that's funny but also
oh that's soothing
and that's what that show brings it's
just calm british people
baking the most drama that they have is
if somebody forgets to preheat their
oven
i haven't eaten some oven oh well
over at the bachelor we're on fire
this whole place is messy it is a hot
mess in here but i do love the bachelor
you know i love this show it's the gift
that keeps on giving and this week it
gave us what we needed
some regal resolution
[Music]
so yes we are getting ready for the rose
ceremony and victoria is curling her
hair i think with a dyson and
katie is trying to just do her makeup in
the light
i loved it cheers to katie she's just
trying you know she's surviving
she's out there on a balcony with her
compact mirror charlotte tilbury i do
like their stuff
we are at the cocktail party and matt is
here to
mix this drink up right i wanted to
address something that was brought to my
attention last night
cheers to matt for pointing out
everything that's been
wrong the environment in the house how
toxic it is
old women and new women this us first
them
really a culture of bullying some rumors
that were floating around
if you're having to belittle someone
else for you to shine then those aren't
the qualities i'm looking for in my life
but
matt is doing more than that matt is
going to go right to the main
ingredients
i don't get enough time with you all and
now i got to deal with this
anthony anna and victoria yes and matt
goes to brittany and he tells her he
knows that this escort rumor is a
complete lie
that's why i wanted to address it
because it is a rumor it's a lie
i see the relief washing over britney's
face and i felt that tune it felt nice
you know it felt like a nice little
cleanse
like we're getting back on the right
track it felt like we'd proven our dough
properly
and it was rising i don't know anything
about baking other than what i've seen
on that show
oh don't put me in a kitchen so anna is
saying that she made a stupid comment i
said something that was rude about
brittany but she's also like
who went to mad about this i'm just like
who the winter
and then anna and matt talk and she
tells him she feels horrible that she
regrets the things she said
i am so sad immediately i felt horrible
about it
that she's breaking out into a rash like
i'm breaking out in a rash because i'm
like
and you know another cheers to matt
because he advises to take
responsibility
and grow ultimately i've had to take
responsibility for
my words and my actions and i've grown
from it rise like that doe
you gotta expand and you gotta rise okay
yeah
why does doe do that anna seems to be
realizing what's happening so she is now
making crying sounds
but rather notably there are no tears
matt says i owe it to these women to
create a safe space for them and he puts
anna
in havana i can't see you being part of
that journey anymore
she goes home in the car she says she is
disappointed in herself
i'm just really disappointed in myself
and that's what it comes down to
and i will say this uh she seemed
unlike some people will get to in a
minute to have some awareness of having
done wrong
and brittany did say at one point that
anna had apologized to her
anna had came up to me to apologize so i
found a little bit of empathy
for anna here what did you guys think of
her exit
let me know in the comments below
thought it was the right thing for matt
to send her home i will say that we got
a clean house here
we got to start fresh we got to clean up
our stations
for the next challenge for the second
challenge
i am getting very specific with these
references
now we get back to the other women i
feel like bullying is a very strong word
and toxic i don't feel like the
environment in the house is toxic
i concur do you guys think it is and i
do
like that the show does this it brings
up these discussions
about real conversations and
interactions that people have in real
life
what crosses lines what becomes too much
obviously we know some things here
too much but it's good to have the
discussions and grow
and it's good to apologize and a lot of
the women do that don't drink for every
apology that is now happening
i feel sick to my stomach that you guys
were going through that and we were just
completely oblivious to it
i apologize for not being more open
and if something does bother you like
please come tell me and we can talk
about it
i'm sorry i took your crown it was just
like affiliate
what did you think of the apologies i
thought some were probably more sincere
than others i do not think that you were
treated fairly
so i wanted to make sure that that was
known to you
and that queues us up perfectly for oh
i'm never like
malicious victoria ryan who's one of the
new women went and spoke to matt and
said
that victoria was part of the reason
that the house environment was toxic
and she owned up to that she told
victoria here's what i said
i mean i talked to him just about how it
has been difficult
i did you know i referenced when you did
the cheers victoria responds by shutting
her down calling her fake
actions look fake towards me walking
away from the conversation in the middle
of the conversation and calling
everybody
losers but then these losers create
these problems when everything is fine
i don't think she gets it and everything
she said in this episode
seemed to prove that she says the other
women are fake
but her good out shines obviously my
good outshines
any of the in the house she said and i
quote
i make the house toxic that's completely
crazy
there's no truth to that i make the
house toxic that's completely
crazy and then and then
and then
she goes and speaks seemingly to a
producer and says
she is the only one for matt literally
there's no one in here he can marry
besides me so it's the rose ceremony and
i thought the order of these roses was
quite telling
brittany gets the first roast and she
deserved that
ryan gets the second rose from us
and she deserved that rachel and serena
p get the next roses
because matt really likes them ladies
matt
is the final rose tonight and victoria
is going home ladies i'm sorry
you did not receive a rose take a moment
say your goodbyes
the queen has been overthrown
also going home are catalina mari and
lauren back to victoria
victoria leaves by saying she knows
she didn't do anything wrong i'm upset
because i know i didn't do anything
wrong and tells matt she feels sorry for
him
i honestly feel so sorry for you that
you would listen to hearsay and not all
of the facts
and perhaps most importantly i think
this was my favorite
this is gonna go down in franchise
history for me
victoria says she hates the name matt
now
never dating another mad as long as i
live ever
i hate that name now we talk about age
and maturity on this franchise this
woman is 27
you know she's in her late 20s like he
chose katie over me
do you think that victoria can learn
from her behavior
and grow she did not do two things that
i think are important
own and atone let me know in the
comments below
the whole house is gonna feel like that
i'm gone like i brought so many people
with joy
you know i did think there was a missed
opportunity here
thought she'd throw the crown let's
bring back the crown and let's throw it
down
you know we're gonna fix it
i'm done and you're all annoying
and i hate the name matt now
hey lauren remind her she's not actually
british
yeah good point and i went a little
dudley dursley there mm-hmm
i'm just done oh everyone all of us
villagers commoners peasants let us
rejoice
the queen is gone the queen
is done the queen has left the castle
the soul i brought so many people
joy she is to that
[Music]
yes we went on this journey of watching
some really toxic behavior
from these adult women and i think that
there is value
in also observing the resolution and
hopefully there's growth there
you know i feel brighter and lighter
we're without the fighter
it's nice you know we're done with that
now we're gonna have a little fun
it's a gift that keeps on giving here's
to
turning a new page and now chris
harrison is coming in here and he is
giving us a date card
and rachel gets a one-on-one and
some kind of white gloved wizard is here
to get
miss rachel hello ladies i'm looking for
miss rachel what was the point of this
man
today is your day i'm gonna spoil you
but rachel is getting a very purposeful
date rachel gets the pretty woman date
[Music]
it's that date we've done before where
we go shopping
but unlike some other dates i never tire
this one
it's a dream date they are in a room
full of beautiful clothes
rachel gets to model them and takes them
home plus
macaroons you guys you guys
you guys i love macaroons
although you shouldn't try to make them
on the great british baking show i have
seen things go terribly wrong when
contestants try to make macaroons
because it's very difficult to get the
crunchiness and the
mushiness the chewiness of the macaroon
perfectly and mary berry will come over
and she will tell you that it is
not a great bake they look okay paul
hollywood will tell you oh
that's not all right here we go so just
be aware that your flavors
can be hard to maintain when you're
trying to get that perfect macaron if
you're making something else like a cake
and you're trying to decorate it with
macaroons they're just not worth the
time they're gonna send you down
anyway i know what i'm having for dinner
so they have macaroons they have
champagne
they have this celebrity stylist guy hey
hi and we've been through so much we
deserve it let's have some fun
don't drink for every dress that rachel
tries on
[Music]
walking down rachel even gets some
louboutin oh my god oh my god what
those red bottom shoes okay
did matt buy them it's a question i
always have
and a lot goes right for matt and rachel
on this date
matt says that he and rachel are very
similar in how they look at
life we kind of are on the same page on
how we carry ourselves
and they have a lovely kiss
[Music]
oh i fear then rachel returns to the
house and of course the other women are
going to be a little jealous
don't drink for every bag that rachel
had
[Music]
cheers to serena p for just saying how
everyone felt
you lucky [ __ ] but i will say
i'm happy to point out i raised my glass
to this the
energy when rachel returned was solid
everybody overall was pretty happy for
her she looks so
happy oh my god we didn't have any of
the queen of mean comments
these losers it was very much like the
atmosphere in the tent where
if you need a spoon your competitor will
grab it for you
it's all about support even in the face
of competition
bake and rachel's date
isn't over i feel like it i love it
her and matt are going to dinner and oh
it's the gift that keeps on giving give
us the romance
romance love we're back where we belong
[Music]
and speaking of love interestingly we
find out that like matt
rachel says she has never been in love
before
one of the things that you had said was
that you'd never been in love before
she also opens up to matt saying she has
low self-confidence
and she even thinks matt is out of her
league i don't have like a lot of
confidence in myself
like i think you're out of my league
what did you think of what rachel had to
share with matt
uh matt then tells her all the things he
likes about her you've never been the
loudest you've never been the first one
to run up
including that she is sure of herself
and you're just assured of yourself
and i was like what are we listening i
don't have like a lot of confidence
she just said she wasn't confident
you're just assured of yourself oh but i
guess we are listening because
they then tell each other that they are
both falling in love
with each other rachel i'm finding up
with you too that they could start a
life together
and i want to start my life with you
that they could walk on out of here
together walk out of here with you told
you guys this date means something
oh or maybe they're just crazy how many
of you are both crazy
what what did you all think of matt and
rachel's conversation i loved seeing
them look in each other's eyes and kind
of feeling the butterflies through the
screen
but one thing i did wonder was if they
both say they've never been in love
then how would they know that they are
both falling in love with each other
you know how many of you are both crazy
let me know in the comments below
because i don't know but i do know that
we need more women just like i need more
wine
it's time for the group date oh and we
had our high highs with our celebrity
stylist and our louboutins
now we're in our low lows the dirt hey
ladies hi
welcome to the farm yes the group date
is on a farm
which means the rachel got champagne and
these women got chickens oh my god
rachel got gowns they get goats
and rachel got designer shoes
yes i think there had to be animal in
there
right right i don't know farms
and as they were going through this date
i did write down
i miss funny people have you guys
noticed there's
not really anybody comedic on this
season you know i i thought back to nick
viall's season where they had a corinne
olympios uh digging through the mud
when they told me i have to shovel poop
i was like why
why i wanted to laugh
you can't escape the poop it's like
everybody turning poop poop
poop and especially with all the meanies
that we had i think we've eated that
are you missing it let me know in the
comments below so yeah we're just
zipping on through this because nothing
was funny uh but we are at the cocktail
party honey and
matt is having some very meaningful
floristy conversations with these women
mercy tells chelsea he's very happy
she's here i'm
very happy you're here and they kiss
then him and abigail get emotional about
growing up without their dads around but
i can relate to
not having a dad growing up and they
kiss and then matt and michelle have a
beautiful chat
i feel what you're feeling and they
really kiss
but matt just told rachel he was falling
in love with her rachel i'm falling in
love with you too
who does matt like yeah you know matt's
hard to read
isn't he the more time i'm spending with
these ladies the stronger my connections
are going
so what do you guys think at this point
who are the five women you think matt is
most interested in
let me know in the comments below who is
he mixing things up in the kitchen with
oh we're gonna get to that later but
first i thought we were finished
with the fighting anyone here would ever
like to talk to me and if we want to get
this out of the way because this does
not need a fester
no
it's been difficult to tell at different
points which women
were really making the most mean
comments
but ultimately i've narrowed it down to
three
our three musketeers
of mean anna she's gone victoria goodbye
but remaining is mj think i was holding
an invisible sword in my hand for that
always on stage in my mind
so matt tells mj that he heard she was
acting in a mean way in the house and
your name came up actually
oh so it was like someone who was like
like an antagonist you're making them
feel like outsiders
and mj doesn't go the ana route i'm just
really disappointed in myself
she leans more victoria obviously my
good outshines
any of the in the house and says that is
not me i lead by example that hurts
because like
at the end of the day like i lead by
example
don't drink every time she said she
leads by example
at the end of the day like i lead by
example i think i lead by example
i know that i'm honest i i lead by
example
i actually speak louder than my words by
example just send you so just you're
gonna
you can actually like if you're doing it
don't have to talk about it because
people see it
did you think she was leading by example
let me know in the comments below
mj goes and speaks to the other women my
character was put in question
tonight um i was called an antagonist in
the house
anyone here would ever like to talk to
me and if we want to get this out of the
way because this does not need a fester
she says that the floor is open for
conversation
the floor is open for a conversation and
i'm saying it like this
because the way that she said it didn't
feel very
open the floor is open for a
conversation
unrelated i do wish someone would have
fixed that one hair of mj's that was out
of place for this conversation
oh they did okay great but we couldn't
fix all this in this moment so bottom
line
abigail gets the rose how'd it go
will you accept this rise and that was
nice because we hadn't seen abigail in a
minute she was a really early favorite
what do you think of abigail and mass
connection at this moment let me know in
the comments below
matt and kit are having a one-on-one
tonight is kids night and
i'm focused on how well we're meshing
tonight
they're baking who cares about dinner
all i care about is cookies
oh we are learning more about kit she
says that she grew up in the spotlight
because her mom is a fashion designer
my mom is a fashion designer and i grew
up in the spotlight
if you didn't know cynthia rowley i get
a lot of cynthia rowley stuff at two of
my favorite places
marshalls and tj maxx cheers to that
fancy oven and kit says she loves being
in that kitchen
she says it a lot don't drink for every
time she says it my happy place is like
in the kitchen with my mom i brought up
to matt
how much cooking means to me so
fancy oven can do this every night
i've told you how much being in the
kitchen means to me
and it just made me feel so much more at
home
kit also reveals that she has never
been in love like i have so much love in
my life
but i've never been able to find that
like with the romantic partners nobody's
been loved this season
are we worried let me know in the
comments below matt and kid have a
lovely date
and a snog british word for kiss
i know my stuff i read a lot of harry
potter but you guys know that
harry potter don't do it
so as calming as i have found this
episode i was now starting to get a
little stressed
because matt really likes kit i love our
time together where will his heart go i
don't know
cute calming sought from the great
british baking show
[Music]
it's a beautiful sponge what did you
guys think of matt and kids date let me
know in the comments below
[Music]
oh but back to the real stress ahead of
the rose ceremony
mj and jacenya have been called in
mj and justinia i need to know the truth
it means that they're kind of going on a
two-on-one but we can't really travel
so you know what this show is the gift
that keeps on giving
they gave me the comedy i needed what
was up with this shot of them both
rolling out their suitcases
they brought them right down to the
lobby it was great it was so over the
top i loved it
then they were rioting in the car
together and i just wrote down
this is awkward this
is embarrassing oh but now they are
waiting for matt and they are fighting
and you guys
you guys you guys i am
just not prepared for more pettiness
i never you lied i never lied you don't
know me
and i stood with jesenya did you let me
know in the comments below
mg said she preaches harmony in peace
you know what i stand for
i preach harmony peace she kept saying
just suddenly was talking over and being
loud when she wasn't
guarantee you he would have more respect
for you if you don't talk
over me just because you say something
louder doesn't mean you're right jesenya
i was getting a headache
and she tells mj you'll find out the
truth
when this all airs you'll find out the
truth when this all airs and so will he
and you know i love when we break the
fourth wall when it's a moment that
deserves
us to do so and i felt that this moment
was do you think mj will own an atone
let me know in the comments below
but we won't find out until next week
next week on the bachelor we get next
week's promo
and there is a fight with katie you're
lighting all these little fires
everywhere you are the freaking arsonist
my heart's so fragile i can't take all
this
oh but luckily tyler cameron's here
thank you bro there's so much
i don't even know where to start and
heather from colton's season arrives
and that's interesting hi chris heather
what are you doing here
you can honestly destroy this whole
thing for matt
what did you all think of this episode i
was glad that we got to feel a little
sane
that we had some resolution and i'm very
excited for what's ahead
tyler cameron bro there's so much i
don't even know where to start
[Laughter]
oh i love you guys so much thank you for
watching roses and rose as always i love
to hear from you so if you want to
connect with me more i am available on
tick tock instagram and twitter all at
laurenzema
you can also get a personal message from
me if you want one for valentine's day
book it
through cameo thank you for watching in
a world full of confusion
you are so often my calm
[Music]
bye